>>> IN SPORTLE,
RODGERS NOW ADG HE NOT
NA
TID
MISLED THEC TO BELIEVE
HE'DN S
BLAMING THE WOKE M FOR HOW
HE'S BEING TREATED.
PERHAPS CREATING A NEW
DEFINITION FOR
CHEE
>>'MRS OF IGHT
W.
SO BEFORE MY FINAL NAIL GETS PUT
Y CANCELTURE CASKETHINK I'D LIKD
STRAIGHT ON SO MANY OF THE
MYSELF RIGHT NOW.T OF
ANAXLAT RTHER. SEBIS CRITICAL
YOI MARCH TO THE BEA MY OWN DRU.
>> AND OF , RSE HE
VOD MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
SAYING THELK JR. S
YOU HAVE AN OBLI T.
>> WHAT DO YOU M
AC THENE WHOE
TO BELIEVE HE HAD BEEN
VA
BEINETED BY A WOKE MOB H I'M T H
HE'S ABOUT.
>> EXACTLYTHIS IS A HUGER BYO H
CAA LONG LIFETIME IN,
WHETHER  HOSTING" ARTS OR CULTU.
WHAT A.
WHAT A SURPRISE THIS IS TH
RE A THAT
DOESN'T
GUTS TO SAY HEN'T CCABLY BECAUSV
O EXPLAIN AWAY HISERRORS HE DID
A MASY AFTED MEET WITH THE
MEAT FACILORS S SUPPOSED
E INATED
CHARADE HENTLY.
MAYBE GO HOME TO A HUSBAND OR  H
SUGOODNE AORRIBLBY
THE SEEING A VERY FFERENDGERSEE
RODGERS THAT PPL,
REALLY BY.
>> HE'TA
G NC
TAO KAEPERNICK ABOUT CIN.
>> YES, HE COULD BE R BEING SO
IT'S A LIT ON THE WRIST.LD SUSP.
THE ODDS IT WILL BE MORE THE
PACKERS TH AND GET SOT A FINE U
L S BAD ISAT OA
INSAID, RDY.
AUDIENCE.LE
AND SO WHAT HE HAS
IRTHNDS
OVERTADIFFERENT THAN YOUR AVERD
POTENTIALLY IN ENDORSEMENTS.
WESEE HO OUT
I'M SUREOT OED AND CONCEREOO
DOING
UGHT YOU WERE SMARTER THAN
>> WHEN YOU ARE A PUBLIC FUR
THERE'S A AIOB
HAVE TO THE PUBLIC IN  INFORMAT
NOJU ABOOURSELF BUT IN
NE
PROTECTIONINHAERIMED HE WOULD H
ACNETHE CDC SAYS.
HE'S SAYING CA HAD COVID
THAT THE A
I MEAN, THAT HAS THEIMPAN S
GHANF GREEN BAY PACKERS, THEREF.
THINK OFHEAN WHO
MA CONVINCED BN THE FENCE
THE VACCINE ANEN TO GET
RODGERS AN
TO.TH
ANDT HE'S IONS OF WHAT IS
SAYING.
SONDS LIKE POT
T LIST SCIEN RTYST AND THEN SAY
THINGS.
ITY AS
T BE TAKING THANS OUT THER T
AGAIN, SURPRISEDIOI
A  TWIST IN THE LIFEF
WE THOUGHT W